everything every week we agree to terms
and conditions and when we do this we
provide companies with a lawful right to
do whatever they want with our data and
with the data of our children's which
makes us wonder how much data are we
giving away of children and what are its
implications I'm an anthropologist and
I'm also the mother of two little girls
and I started to become interested in
these questions in 2015 when I suddenly
realized that they were vast almost
unimaginable amounts of data traces that
are being produced and collected about
children so I launched the research
project which is called child data
citizen and that aimed a feeling in the
blank now you may think that I'm here to
blame you for posting photos of your
children on social media but that's not
really the point the problem is way
bigger than so-called sharing thing this
is about systems not individuals you and
your habits are not to blame for the
very first time in history we are
tracking the individual data of children
from long before they're born
sometimes from the moment of conception
and then throughout their lives
you see when parents decide to conceive
they go online to look for ways to get
pregnant or they download the relation
tracking apps when they do get pregnant
they post ultrasound of their babies on
social media they download pregnancy
apps or they consult dr. Google for all
sorts of things like you know for
miscarriage risk when flying or
abdominal cramps in early pregnancy I
know because I've done it and many times
and then when the baby's born they track
every now every
every life event on different
technologies and all these technologies
transform the babies most intimate
behavioral and health data into profit
by sharing it with others so to give you
an idea of how this works in 2019 the
British Medical Journal published the
research that showed that out of 24
mobile health apps 19 shared information
with third parties and these third
parties shared information with 216
other organizations of this 216 other
fourth parties only three belonged to
the health sector the other companies
that had access to that data were big
tech companies like Google Facebook or
Oracle they were digital advertising
companies and there was also a consumer
credit reporting agency so you gave
right ad companies and credit agency may
already have data points on little
babies but mobile apps web searchers and
social media are really just the tip of
the iceberg because children are being
tracked by multiple technologies in
their everyday life they are tracked by
home technologies and virtual assistants
in their homes they are tracked by
educational platforms and educational
technologies in their schools they are
tracked by online records and online
portals as their doctor's office
district by the internet connect the
toys the online games and many many many
many other technologies so during my
research a lot of parents came up to me
and they were like so what why does it
matter if my children are being tracked
we can nothing's right well it matters
it matters because today individuals are
not only being tracked they are also
being profiled on the basis of their
data traces artificial intelligence and
predictive analytics are being used to
harness as much data as possible of an
individual life from different sources
family history
purchasing habits social media comments
and then they bring this data together
to make data-driven decisions about the
individual and these technologies are
used everywhere banks use them to decide
loans he sure's use them to decide
premiums recruiters and employers use
them to decide whether one is a good fit
for a job or not also the police and
courts use them to determine whether one
is a potential criminal or is likely to
recommend a crime we have no knowledge
or control over the ways in which those
who buy sell and process our data are
profiling us and our children but these
profiles can come to impact our rights
in significant ways to give you an
example in 2018 the New York Times
published a the news that the data that
had been gathered through online college
planning service there are actually
completed by millions of high school
kids across the u.s. who are looking for
a college program or a scholarship had
been sold to educational data brokers
now educational well researches afford
them who studied educational data
brokers revealed that these companies
profile kids as young as two on the
basis of different categories admittedly
religion athletes social awkwardness and
many other random categories and then
they sell these profiles together with
the name of the kids the home address
and the contact details to different
companies including trading career
institutions student loans and student
credit card companies to push the
boundaries the researchers afford them
asked an educational data broker to
provide them with a list of 14 to 15
year old girls who were interested in
fam
planning services the data broker agreed
to provide them the list so imagine how
intimate and how intrusive that is for
our kids but educational data brokers
are really just an example the truth is
that our children are being profiled in
ways that we cannot control but that can
significantly impact their chances in
life so we need to ask ourselves can we
trust these technologies when it comes
to profiling our children can we my
answer is no as an anthropologist I
believe that artificial intelligence and
predictive analytics can be great to
predict the course of a disease or to
fight climate change so we need to
abandon the belief that these
technologies can object sleep profile
humans and that we can rely on them to
make data-driven decisions about
individual lives because they can't
profile humans data traces are not the
mirror of who we are you must think one
thing and say the opposite feel one way
and act differently algorithmic
predictions or our digital practices
cannot account for the unpredictability
and complexity of human experience but
on top of that these technologies are
always always in one way or another
biased
you see algorithms are by definition
sets or rules or steps that have been
designed to achieve a specific result
okay but these sets of rules or steps
cannot be objective because to be
designed by human beings within specific
cultural context and are shaped by
specific cultural values so when
machines learn they learn from biased
algorithm and they often learn from
biased databases as well at the moment
we're seeing the first examples of
algorithmic bias and some of these
examples are frankly terrifying this
year the AI now Institute in New York
published a report that reveals that the
AI technologies that are being used
for predictive policing have been
trained on dirty data this is basically
data that had been gathered during
historical periods of known racial bias
and non-transparent police practices
because these technologies are being
trained with dirty data terminal
objective and their outcomes are only
amplifying and perpetrating police bias
and error so I think we you're faced
with a fundamental problem in our
society we are started to trust
technologies when it comes to profiling
human beings we know that in profiling
humans these technologies are always
going to be biased and are never really
going to be accurate so what we need now
is actually political solutions we need
governments to recognize that our data
rights are our human rights
until this happens we cannot hope for a
more just future I worried that my
daughters are going to be exposed to all
sorts of algorithmic discrimination and
error you see the difference between me
and my daughter is that there is no
public record out there of my childhood
certainly no database of all the stupid
things that have done and thought when I
was a teenager well but for my
daughter's this may be different the
data that is being collected from them
today may be used to judge them in the
future and can come to prevent their
hopes and dreams I think that it's time
it's time that we all step up it's time
that we start working together as
individuals as organizations and as
institutions and that we demand greater
data justice for us and for our children
before it's too late
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]